let's get to it what's up everyone i
want to take a few minutes let us hear
what kobe bryant had to say shortly
before he died regarding
and i'd say lesson two
would be just five minutes of quiet time
five minutes for you to be mindful
and to just sit and uh and find that
inner voice and uh and just kind of
listen to the self and
preferably would be in the morning
as you start your day and then we'll go
ahead and close it off if you're brave
enough to stick around with everyone's
favorite topic death school senior is in
the hospital after collapsing on the
tennis courts breaking new details on
the deaths of a high school soccer
player finland denmark star man
christian eriksen collapsing towards the
end of the first half the kennedy high
community mourning tonight after one of
their high school football players died
a south carolina high school football
player has died after collapsing at
football practice star college
basketball player collapsing on the
court we want to warn you the video may
be difficult to watch florida gators
start deante johnson collapsing during
the game a west catholic high school
student has died after collapsing during
a football scrimmage on mile eight she
suddenly felt fuzzy and blacked out
seventeen-year-old ryan jacob's heart
stopped unexpectedly collapsed on the
field megan went into cardiac arrest
collapsing during friday night's
football game
now quickly for the basketball lovers
pretty much all of you know who kobe
bryant was but
for the non-basketball fans in short he
was a very famous basketball player who
died with several others back in january
2020 i believe in a sad and tragic
helicopter crash now it was very
interesting to see this video that he
made before he died and i just want you
to replace or make a word adjustment
from the word meditation to the word
prayer vicar i meditate every day i
meditate every day and
i do it in the mornings and i do it for
about 10 to 15 minutes
and
i i think it's important because it just
it it it sets me up for the rest of the
day
you know it helps me it's like it's like
it's like having an anchor
you know it's it's uh if i don't do it i
feel like i'm constantly chasing the day
as it's a very sad reality to see much
of our young youth falling into this
trap
where they end up going to the secular
atheist universities
they listen to some of the sorry to say
goofball professors who they hold in
high esteem and respect who argue
against god a creator prayer even to the
point of making fun and jokes of the
whole concept
while the professors are giving them
dawah towards what nihilism the
rejection of religious and moral
principles
in the belief that life is meaning less
so they take them from living a
purposeful life to ultimately a
meaningless life because after you get
through all the partying drinking zina
fornication the running around life
chasing your tail or your desires
filling your belly feeding your ego life
becomes really just meaningless because
you're not living for an ultimate higher
goal and purpose
like for your creator and the hereafter
so as i often repeat look our measuring
stick is not science or famous
celebrities the quran and authentic
sunnah but if you have someone like a
kobe bryant who had a really big
influence over many people and he's
sharing with you something that was very
critical for his life and now and how he
started his days and things that
may be lying beneath the surface that
if you don't have that time to sit
quietly on your own you'll never pay
attention to
you know because if you think about it
like you know the reality is we're
paying attention to so many things that
are going on around us
we're constantly
taking selfies we're constantly taking
pictures to post on instagram and all
these other things we're constantly
observing everything that's around us
but we don't take the time to really
observe what's going on inside of
ourselves so much so that even the most
renowned basketball coach phil jackson
had the whole team doing it in 2000 we
had a new head coach that came to the
los angeles lakers by the name of phil
jackson
and phil was just coming off and winning
six championships with the bulls
and he was really big on mindfulness
really big on meditation and it wasn't
an option for us
now i want you to imagine if this was
applied not to just one aspect in life
basketball
but for our whole existence called life
and it revolved around praying to the
only one
even though we don't pray because
science says prayer is good or because
there are new studies that now show
people who pray are healthier happier
than those who don't but it's nice to
read these new developments i want to
share with you and you can share with
others encouraging them to pray
and this is the real ultimate if you
want if you want to call it that
meditation or a time to reflect over
your existence
how you came into being
while you're here
and where you're going when you
ultimately die just like kobe bryant
died okay let's get into this article
and we'll start finishing up from there
inshallah this is a very interesting
article
it's titled why people who pray are
healthier than those who don't and if
you want to achieve maximum health there
are a few things that you should do
it starts off to say exercise regularly
eat nutritious and minimally processed
food like i often say eat real food
avoid fake food and drop those extra
pounds and
it finishes off to say pray and i would
just add we would add prey
then it goes on to say that's right
regular prayer
and we would say salah and meditation
has been shown in numerous scientific
studies to be an important factor in
living longer and staying healthy
prayer is the most widespread
alternative therapy in america today
over 85 percent of people con
confronting a
major illness prey
prayer is the most widespread
alternative therapy in america today
over 85 percent of people confronting a
major illness prey according to
a university of rochester study there is
a far
higher that is far higher than taking
herbs or pursuing other non-traditional
healing methods and increasingly the
evidence is that prayer works so this
article is saying the studies show that
prayer actually works and this is
something that your professor will have
you not believe and this is something
that the professor hides behind his
belief in scientism that's his religion
but we're that's why we're sharing with
you some
actual science here for
prayer it goes on to say the
relationship between prayer and health
has been the subject of scores of
double-blind studies over the past four
decades dr herbert benson a
cardiovascular specialist at the harvard
medical school and a pioneer in the
field of mind-body medicine discovered
what he calls the relaxation response
which occurs during periods of prayer
and meditation at sometimes the body's
metabolism decreases
the heart rate slows blood pressure goes
down and our breath becomes calmer and
more regular going towards the end of
the article
it finishes off with saying in one
national institutes of health funded
study
individuals who pray daily and this is
just to know us as muslims we pray five
times a day minimum who pray daily were
shown to be forty percent less likely to
have blood pressure high blood pressure
than those
without a regular prayer practice
research at darmo medical school found
that patients with strong religious
beliefs
who underwent elective heart surgery
were three times more likely to recover
than those who were less religious a
2011 study of the inner city youth with
asthma by researchers at the university
of cincinnati indicates that those who
practice prayer meditation experience
fewer and less severe symptoms than
those who had not
other studies show that prayer boosts
the immune system and helps to lessen
the severity and frequency of a wide
range of illnesses a recent study in the
journal of gerontology
of four thousand senior citizens in
durham
found that people who prayed or
meditated coped better with illness and
lived
longer than those who did not and this
is a longer article but just going down
to the end it says what science can tell
us is that people who pray and meditate
trend to be statistically more healthy
and live longer than those who do not
whether these boons are merely
unintended side effects
of still deeper spiritual benefits
remains a matter of faith
so when you read all these benefits i
mean obviously we don't do it because
science says it's good religion and
spirituality be measured scientifically
intensive research on the brain says the
answer is yes
and now these developments are coming to
the forefront
i mean we base it on proof and evidence
that the quran is indeed from the
creator of him is an earth and over and
over it's talking about establishing a
direct connection with the creator of
the heavens and earth and that that's
not because god almighty allah needs it
is because we need it just like kobe
bryant he needed this anchoring himself
he called it to go ahead and start his
day just like the phil jackson you know
this world-renowned coach he gets his
team to go ahead and meditate to go
ahead and focus we need to focus on what
our purpose in life our creator so it
can make us more morally upright so we
can be better human beings
the world we live in a better place for
all of humanity so i'm gonna make this
really simple and easy when you're
praying
what you don't do is you don't give
one-third
to a human being to an angel to a saint
to jesus
you don't give one third to mary you
don't give one-third to anyone else
all hundred percent of your prayer
goes towards god almighty the creator
allah this is very important
no one in the middle between you and
your creator
you
only call upon the one
the one who created you and before you
start asking for this is very important
now before you start asking for good
health good husband or wife good car
good job good food etc we people ask for
we ask for everything other than the
most important thing you got to start
asking for the guidance
you got to start asking for the guidance
the one who created me
guide me guide me guide me guide me to
what my purpose is guide me from what
you want from me you might be confused
and you see all these different
religions and 99 of them are man-made
religions and you want to go towards the
way of light that's from your creator
ask the creator the heavens and earth to
make it clear and here is an ultimate
prayer that you can start doing today
last but not the least my brothers and
sisters and dean and humanity
the
back to what should really motivate us
and that's the matter that we should
really take serious death
any signs no for this race absolutely
not she felt like she's in the best
shape of her life that's incredible
[Music]
goodness has gone down there erickson is
worrying
he collapsed he collapsed
[Music]
well this is really disturbing
what's happened to one of the referees
[Music]
this does look serious
and we see how again going back to how
we started with kobe bryant he did not
think that that helicopter was going to
crash
and you think you're healthy you're
young i got time i'll do hajj i'll start
praying i'll start fasting i'll start
living islam submission to the creator
not the creation i'll start living it
when i get older
if you're thinking this type of way
believe me
believe you me shaytan is pimping you he
is deceiving you
do you think all these young strong best
trained athletes thought death or
whatever condition reached them would
just look these were some of the best
trained
the most
paid these were people who had the best
coaches the best training
regimen
fitness
optimal and
they did not expect to be playing soccer
to be playing a sport whatever the case
and how about all these are just the
people that we see
what about all those people who are not
as important
where the media doesn't catch this that
are just dying daily
that you won't hear about on the news
and their stories won't be told how many
of those people and that can be you
tomorrow today
so it's very important that we take this
matter serious and the prayer
to the one and only created the heavens
and earth the same god that jesus
worshipped moses abraham the last the
final message prophet muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him this is the start
this is your connection
to your creator through the prayer no
prayer
it's life like god almighty described in
the quran it's like the difference
between the living and the dead so you
got to awaken your heart and your soul
and give your soul give your heart what
it needs and he's that fuel
and that fuel can only come
through the prayer
and
that's it that's it for now brother and
sister that's it for now now to get your
free copy of the quran visit the
show.com if you'd like more evidence if
you're new to the channel
if you're new
and you're to
learning about islam and you want more
evidence and proof
you want to know look you like what we
have to say the pure monotheism that
islam is about
and you want to learn more
to know without a shadow of dr that the
quran is indeed the verbatim word of god
almighty and it's not just based on
hearsay go ahead and call us 1-800-662
and keep me in your prayers keep in your
door subscribe
go ahead and quick note
if you knew just by hitting the like
button
with the proper intention of helping
this video to grow
so it can be a source of goodness and
guidance for someone out there
and just by doing this simple act of
clicking the like button you'll get
rewarded
you do it right now wouldn't you so go
ahead and hit that like button so we can
go ahead and get this video out you can
develop some more traction it could be a
source of guidance and goodness
for humanity in the world
and subscribe
and support us on our patreon page we'll
see you next time until then and and
share share your thoughts and your
comments
uh below
thank you we'll see you next time peace
be with you assalamu alaikum